Mark Steyn is an author and columnist
and he joins us tonight so Mark III I
think the the best summary of the
argument against this from the federal
point of view came out today in in the
onion which quoted an imaginary federal
official is saying and I'm quoting if we
take away the public's faith in this
shadowy monolith all that's left is an
extensive network of rogue unelected
intelligence officers carrying out
extrajudicial missions for a variety of
subjective and occasionally personal
reasons and we wouldn't write that
exactly and as you noted the Washington
Post has come out against the release of
the Bevo that this is the newspaper that
every couple of years Hollywood makes a
movie about with Katharine Graham the
late owner and Ben Bradley the late
editor said oh yeah I'm I i-i'll go to
jail publish this and I'm prepared to
take the risk of going to jail and Tom
Hanks and gets all the looks forward to
all the Oscar nominations and all the
rest of it and that every actor would
kill to play The Washington Post Ono
says I'm gonna go to jail I'm publishing
the memo and I'm willing to go to jail
and then they're in the real back in the
real world they say oh no no no you are
people out there you don't need to know
this it could greatly impair all all our
shadowy deep state bureaucracies if you
were to see this memo there's a kind of
conflict there Wow so democracy dies in
darkness but not in this specific case
is there and you've covered a lot of
national security stories for decades
I've read them do you think there are
legitimate reasons to withhold this memo
from public view I don't think so
because I we live in leaky times and so
far we've had an investigation about
supposed Russian government interference
in the u.s. election for which there is
very minimal evidence whereas in the
course of the investigation a lot of
evidence has emerged about American
government interference in the election
which ought to be a lot more concern
and we have seen texts we've seen emails
reports of meetings phrases that a prima
facie suspicious such as insurance
policy
and the idea that the whole thing is one
big massive fruit of the poisonous tree
the poisonous tree being a memo that was
paid for by the Democrats with input
from the Russians purely for the purpose
of enabling the party in government to
spy on its political opponents that's
the scandal that's why the American
people are entitled to see the memo
if this memo were not released and I
think that it will be imminently but
let's say it weren't released and the
supporting documents remain cloaked
under their classified status wouldn't
that abet the most destructive kind of
distrust in government and conspiracy
theories in exactly the kind of
discourse that really does undermine a
country it seems to me I mean sunlight
really is needed here well yes I mean
you you look at it if you are say flad
amir putin and you wanted to interfere
in america's election what's actually
serves your purposes more trying to find
a candidate who will be your stooge or
actually creating conditions where there
is a paralyzed relationship between the
permanent bureaucracy and the government
and recive mistrust of all government
institutions I mean in effect the Russia
investigation itself is a huge victory
for Putin and I wouldn't I would say one
others India - yeah I would say one
other thing here to Tucker this
investigation isn't where it ought to be
right now mala is on the backfoot the
FBI is on the backfoot
and Trump is actually teaching a lesson
here if you look at what happened to the
Bush administration during that
disgraceful Scooter Libby investigation
a few years ago where Bush took the high
road and steered clear of it and it was
immensely damaging to him a Trump on the
other hand is saying that
yes there is a bigger scandal here and
so far that biggest scandal is out
punching the so-called Russia
investigation so far that's right and I
think the memo will shine a lot of light
in that in either direction mark Stein
thank you for that it was interesting